got basically three sub brands now
you've got mercedes-benz you've got AMG
for the sport sporting people and you've
got Maybach bringing it back for the
total luxury so how's that has that work
well Mercedes is the ultimate in modern
luxury and with mercedes AMG as a sub
brand we establish successfully a
performance brand especially now with
products such like the GT what you can
see here but on the other hand on the
top top luxury and we decided to
establish the Mercedes Maybach as a sub
brand of Mercedes for the ultimate
luxury what you can see over there let's
take a look at them I mean I wonder what
you feel you design this car it's
absolutely gorgeous interest when you
see it in person it's even more stunning
than when you see it in pictures but it
is kind of reminiscent of a Jaguar
e-type was that intentional no of course
not this car and body is all the racing
heritage of decades of Silver Arrows it
has all the DNA in there it has this
huge long hood the windshield is pushed
back the car sits on the rear wheel
which is the transmission wheel you know
see the shoulder and yang out here this
is the coolest part of it look at this
beauty you know you simply want to touch
it so everything is integrated smoothly
sophisticatedly into each other so hood
also I mean get get a shot at how long
this hood is it's unbelievable look at
the curvature look at the power Delmas
here look at the exposed fenders you
know this is pure shape you know about
timeless but but beautiful you know
Mercedes all about intelligence and
emotional both come together so the
Maybach is back here I want to get a
quick look at it we don't much time but
Trish this is what i'll probably be
bringing back to you from Los Angeles
is the first Maybach that we're going to
see right yes you see this car has about
eight inches of extra length now the car
is trench we have this huge c-pillar you
know which gives a lot of state a
separate window the Maybach logo at the
once the sea para and of course we have
this big three-dimensional chrome trim
around it's got the privacy glass in
Trish I'll wear a chauffeur's hat and
you'll sit back here I believe you can
add massaging seats they can happily
recline like in an airplane and I heard
something about it covent coming with
its own silver goblets is that true yes
of course we have champagne glasses here
out of Silva you know but of course like
you mentioned we have a first-class bad
here so your chauffeur can drive you
around while why you sleep it's a
perfect craftsmanship it's a cocoon of
luxury and so it is a top in luxury you
can get all right